hey guys how's it going this is our
third day New York and I'm heading to a
little fan meetup event and then later
I'm presenting a Trank cast so I'm
pretty excited it's really fun I'm so
great actually getting to see all the
youtubers here it's like we never are
all in the same place at the same time
and actually get to hang out cuz usually
a big con everybody has to go to events
and do stuff so you don't actually just
see each other there it is really
important to be 5 and sunny no snow it
is it's so much hotter than me so the
dude perfect eyes are over here trying
to get some shots but I kind of think
they might need my help I think you guys
need my help
I'm really excited I'm first in line
I've been here since 5:00 a.m. he was
camped out yeah she was downtown
yeah that's true so should we like shoot
a couple we should okay hold on
Wow that's pretty crazy
specs of gaming on YouTube are let's
play videos these people play game but
they express opinions about games and
they have fun in games
I'm still very happy still smiling talk
to anyone in the video game industry and
they say hey our game is covered by
these creators we see this huge spike in
interest
and now please welcome to the stage
youtuber Jeff Dean is Eric
know what I was asked to host tonight's
gaming section I was so excited so I've
been a game on my entire life simply
want to take notes back here that's me
at five years old and my little Mario
t-shirt and that was shortly after my
parents got with my first attendant
console so I thought that I was the
coolest kid in town and you can imagine
that if I loved tutorials at this lunch
and the child how excited I was to
actually interview the creator of Mario
25 years later now as a youtuber I
couldn't think of two better photos to
illustrate Who I am
Venice no growing up well some kids
we're going to the movies they were
going to the prom I went to game parties
which we called LAN parties before the
internet so it's kind of he had so we
had to do we haven't learned around
these gigantic desktop computers and we
don't play quake 3 we play Unreal
Tournament all night and my mom was a
little worried but sorry it all worked
out because I started uploading gaming
and tech videos to my youtube channel
back in 2006 my first huge hit was a
video of me reviewing a 300-page phone
bill that got the mail game in a box
something you might remember that no I
learned the hard way not to get text
every time someone comments with all the
social media post it's like there were
50,000 actually
in a month the next thing that I do I
was being interviewed of like dozens of
news outlets like CNN or any calling
means it's very strange I think that was
the moment for me I blessed this is what
you think it is extremely powerful
I just got back to my room and I've had
such an amazing time here I'm extremely
tired so forgive my slurring of my
speech and the fact that I'm probably
falling asleep right now but I had such
a great time here this weekend in New
York getting to hang out with so many
amazing creators and I was really cool
was actually very inspiring because a
lot of us create so much content by
ourselves and to be able to actually see
our fellow youtubers and get to talk to
them and talk about I don't know
different stuff that we all deal with
and it was really fun it was great I had
a great time and now I'm gonna go to bed
you do this what the hell is that what
the hell is that
okay well there you have it I'll see you
guys tomorrow or whenever I love you bye
I hope this place isn't burning down
because I'm too tired and I'm about to
put my pajamas on I'm trying to sleep
what the hell
oh my god if I drop my camera oh I've
been known
okay well I guess
a nice man came over the loudspeaker and
said that it was a false alarm so cool
thanks cool story
oh my gosh this is heavy no no a little
bad door open two thumbs open okay oh my
god
I don't like New York I don't like New
York City it's not for me